auch gleich bei deinem was kann man sich
da verkaufen
du hast keine ahnung ich hatte keine
blöcke hallo leute was ist das mit hilfe
des staates
ja ich bin heute der tastatur ich gegen
liebe herren sg kfh moz was geht machen
oder png jpg
ich bin ich jetzt richtig mache ich
nicht mit kein tage an okay weil mir ist
egal ich mache man es direkt auf mich
geht's denn dann weiß dann fest dass ich
immer schon vorwarnung in fünf tagen
kommt von protein mcus wenn ihr neuer
tag lautet wieder alle für die der colt
achtzehnter bei magneten an wir acht
zehntel spar ohne an 16 kommt er in
neuen tags werden komplett läuft aber
egal wenn der kommt an bord die für den
auf weil darf man schon public sagen was
ergebnis sein könnte und zwar wenn ihr
da fleißig geordert und supporter dann
könnte liebe essen und ich nach amerika
leiten
der glamour aber vielleicht ein erstes
treffen vielleicht da gibt es auf jeden
fall amerika als zu gewinnen die dann
natürlich ausführlich mit widex
begleitet werden würde
und von daher jetzt schon mal gerne da
aktiv werden ja und grüße an mcdonald's
dass sie sich so viel post promo oder
überhaupt homogen ohne irgendein cent
dafür zu bezahlen
überhaupt ist hier selber hat eben pop
lady wo bist du damit du spielst du bist
das erste mal gerade dann weißt du schon
das duell reckt werden kannst du musst
es gibt teleporter hier wird wirst was
hinter deiner insel und hinter meiner
insel auch ist diese teleporter
importieren hin hinter die insel vom
andern also nein doch nicht
aber das hat eine coole komponente sind
man muss sich dann trotzdem noch ein
paar parameter hin bauen soll
aber das finde ich eine coole komponente
um das spiel so interessanter zu machen
sobald klar ist einer von zwei seiten
angegriffen
naja ok jetzt sehe ich dachte da würde
ich direkt in meine pace an rein pflegen
die aber so ist sie übrigens gibt es bei
dem ersten port glaube bei den ersten
zwei ports gibt es eine nachricht und
also wird man nicht so heftig überrascht
das kann sie ganz schön gut aus aber der
modus kann das sein
nö eigentlich basic nalitch was man
kennen sollte wenn man auf den street 2
aber ich war hier noch nie und ich war
nicht ab ich wohl in den screens wohne
in exchange of straße die körper was ist
eigentlich los mbc der babypause
nein nein nicht wirklich money boy und
so weil sein kompletter twitter-account
wurde gesperrt
warum wahrscheinlich weil er ja alle
irgendwie nach mehrjährigen gehalts
geführt hat so über twitter ich finde
ich alles legitim so wie cox das hier
sehen dann
und spaß kommt mal runter wie money boy
das hilft hat wirklich wenn man so
schreibt also einfach alle auf twitter
macher steht wie man lieber schreiben
der staatsanwaltschaft immer so ok wie
auf twitter geschrieben jetzt gerade
okay nur nur 10.000 mal das reicht noch
nicht
aber wenn dir jetzt 50.000 freilassen
natürlich group jetzt immer im kreis ja
klar ist aber auch gut so
es ist schon richtig sonst alles seine
richtigkeit
es ist eigentlich wollte schwachsinnig
reserven anzulegen ich war einfach
gerade also nur mal kurz mal den
spielmodus hier zu loben
ich freue mich einfach geradeheraus und
der block den ich unter mich gesetzt
habt ihr verschwindet einfach nur und
ich fahr runter dankeschön hier
anscheinend immer was zu meckern kann es
vielleicht sein
jedes kann nicht sein aber ich habe
gewisse ansprüche ja ok und diese
ansprüche geht es zu befriedigen okay
man ist ja echt information sagen sie
gefehlt das ist etwas werden könnte
glaube es ist am morgen und basiert auf
einem skript ohne ist die high stakes
goldmarkt nein ich habe kein gold seit
drei jahren hast du es sein erstes gold
geholt und ja man wird dich ins eiskalte
wasser hier keine ahnung von der
stimmung weiß nicht wie man beides
spielt dann erwähnt ja ja ich weiß man
beim spielen so unüblich dass es bei
detmold in der mitte blieb und so ja ich
weiß ich doch aber das hier ein
spitzenjahr schnauz jetzt also manch das
reichsmark
es reicht hier gleich was ins gewicht
ein einschlag auch was feines für silber
okay das klopp team ist die armenierin
after kehre ich bin ehrenmann
ich habe falsch gehört glied ich wollte
auf dem bogen und hatte aber die
spitzhacke eine hand weiß weitgehend
habe irgendwas falsch gelegen
ich wollte ich nach hinten weg schieben
aber ich sage es mal so der bvse
prepared lässt sich von nichts so
schnell aus so genannte möglich geheim
fallen die republik kennen muss aber
zugleich wasser so dass mich für nichts
so schnell aus der ruhe bringen wollte
veh nicht aus der ruhe bringen
aber lass dich von jemandem aus der ruhe
bringen nämlich bin 1 flüsse rhein
gefallen lasse ich mich retten oder
genau in nordrhein-westfalen mussten den
nordrhein westfalen
51 wir mussten nicht nicht irgendwie
rein fahren sondern westfalen
ich finde dich du bist auch so ein glück
die unterschlagen wurden
man wird einfach unterschiedlich ist
voriges bauern so dass man gespannt sein
willst du sein würde ich sagen kinder
massiv sei einfach kaputt
er wird eingebaut hat junge ganze zeit
gemacht hast ja ich habe irgendwie
versuchen den spielmodus klar zu kommen
wir nicht ganz genau wo ich vorne bis
hinten
ich hab zum arag kann es sein das kann
man nicht mehr verkaufen
du hast kein junger ich hatte keine
blöcke
der liegt ja wie gedrückt
die machen auch gleich sei einfach
ehrlich mit mir hast du keine chance aus
direkt mal für alle
das war das was serious gaming alter
doch das wasser aus auf das war echt gut
war echt richtig gut machst hast nix
erzählen von der ganzen welt da draußen
die bekommt man immer noch dein bett was
ein bisschen ja das ist sport und wie
stein check meinte ich bin nicht da also
ich muss ganz ehrlich sagen
suzuki habe ich habe noch eine menge
pfeile und konnte gar nichts alles klar
wir haben sie clips und bänder clubs
helfen willst du mich warum warum warum
ich habe voll daneben geschlagen alter
schöner mist ich war ich hatte richtig
gutes equipment
naja schade dass es wurden mich aber
dafür war der bub war richtig cool heute
gewartet und dann ist und darauf
ansonsten eine sehr fähige aufnahm ich
trotzdem check teske aus der distanz
unter der beschreibung wie es noch was
sagen tschüss